bills bills and more bills just how much
does your household energy consumption
eat into your monthly budget do you feel
the way you're paying is fair and have
you ever considered switching to
renewables terisa griffin is authoring a
parliamentary initiative to get a better
deal on energy for consumers she wants
pills of state the facts clearly and
give consumers the tools to switch to
cheaper suppliers the report also aims
to help the most vulnerable figure
suggests at 50 million Europeans live in
mg poverty some of these in energy
poverty if they're having to make a
choice for instance between heating
their food or paying their energy bills
or if they live in southern Europe
putting their air conditioning on
because it's very hot outside and people
are actually dying because they're
frightened of the bills this cannot be
right in 2016 it's a scandal reduce
charges is what we want to achieve
competition of course is vital for that
and indeed empowerment of individual
consumers may be to work on the
co-operative model so they can supply
their own energy and I think there's a
huge scope for that it happens in some
countries like Denmark I think it is
something we would like to see given to
all communities into the future a future
of lower bills and more choice could be
the way ahead for consumers if any Peas
have their way